les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de Franz 24 abrimos Este
programa con dos series que nos llamaron
la atención en enero empezando con
caleidoscopio de Erick García en Netflix
es la primera producción de la
plataforma que puedes ver en cualquier
orden y es por este concepto que está
puesta vale la pena y no por su historia
un poco más clásicas sobre un arriesgado
atraco y su equipo de personajes
carismáticos los ocho episodios no
tienen números sino colores por lo que
hay más de 5000 combinaciones posibles
para descubrir Qué pasó antes y después
de este robo que acontece en el capítulo
blanco una estructura narrativa única
que involucra al espectador en este
rompecabezas Temporal y busca innovar en
un momento en que la competencia es
feroz entre las plataformas de streaming
otra serie sobre la que se habló mucho
este mes es son las hojas en hbo escrita
y producida por crekmassin y Neil
dracman en esta adaptación ya aclamada
por la crítica de las muy exitosas
franquicias de videojuegos de
PlayStation seguimos el viaje de dos
supervivientes de una pandemia provocada
por un Dumbo que hace mutar a los seres
humanos en criaturas caníbales es una
serie Sangrienta pero también con un
buen desarrollo de las emociones de los
personajes y visualmente preciosa
miramos el traidor
[Música]
Hablamos ahora de la edición número
festival el primer Festival de cine en
lengua francesa totalmente en línea
solamente necesitan un computador y una
conexión a internet para poder descubrir
gratis y con subtítulos en español Los
29 largometrajes y 10 cortometrajes que
hacen parte de la programación de este
año les recomendamos en particular la
delicada película una historia de amor y
de deseo de la directora Leila la pueden
ver como las demás en el sitio web del
festival my french festival Punto Com en
otras noticias Italia dijo adiós a una
de sus máximas representantes del cine y
la fotografía Gina loro brigida falleció
el 16 de enero a los 95 años actuó con
los más grandes de su época en los años
50 y 60 como Frank Sinatra después de
una exitosa carrera en Hollywood regresó
a Italia Para volver a su primer amor la
fotografía y luego escultura a la que se
dedicó por completo hasta el final de su
vida
y del lado de Brasil el mes de enero
estuvo marcado por el ataque por parte
de miles de partidarios del expresidente
de plan alto al tribunal supremo y al
congreso y los daños incalculables que
dejó dentro de las destrucciones hay
varias obras de arte mientras el
gobierno está movilizando a
restauradores la nueva ministra de
cultura margaret Meneses dijo que evalúa
la posibilidad de utilizar esas obras
para formar un Memorial la escuchamos
La idea es crear un Memorial sobre esta
violencia que sufrimos para que nunca
vuelva a ocurrir se trata de un tesoro
artístico del pueblo brasileño que
pertenece a la nación y cuya integridad
debe ser respetada por lo tanto es una
violencia muy respetuosa y profunda
y este Memorial es para que nunca vuelva
a ocurrir otra violencia de este nivel
con la memoria y con nuestra Intocable
democracia
cerramos Este programa de cultura con
nuestra sección dedicada a la música y
los dos temas que están rompiendo todos
los récords hablo obviamente de la
colaboración entre la cantante
colombiana Shakira y el productor
argentino visará más de 150 millones de
vistas en YouTube en una semana
[Música]
y de la nueva canción de la
estadounidense Miley Cyrus flowers que
se posicionó directamente número 1 en
las escuchas de la plataforma de Spotify
el punto en común letras que hablan de
las exparejas de las dos estrellas de la
música Pero dentro de los miles de
análisis sobre estas dos canciones este
artículo de la periodista Alba Correa
publicado en España hizo una pregunta
interesante artísticamente que convierte
en eterna una condición de ruptura la
periodista destaca entre otras cosas un
tuit de la escritora Carmen Pacheco
subrayando que la letra muy personal de
la canción de Shakira donde nombra
directamente a su esposo y su actual
pareja Clara chía no deja espacio para
identificarse mientras que Miley cyrusen
flowers explota imágenes universales
acude al denominador común en resumen
sobre este tema de empoderamiento y su
positiva y bailable la periodista
concluyó nos hemos reconocido hoy pero
hay muchas posibilidades de que Flower
sea eterna y Dentro de 10 años continúe
acudiendo al rescate de corazones
heridos
Nos despedimos con otro estreno musical
de esta semana de los rockeros italianos
Gracias a ustedes por su confianza y
sigan con nosotros hay más culturas 24.1
[Música]